metro police saying late rent is what
led a man to shoot and kill two women
here in las vegas 79-year-old arnaldo
sanchez is now behind bars in connection
with the double murder another victim
remains in the hospital at this hour
thanks for joining us here at four i'm
kirsten joyce and i'm christian casa as
we begin with that developing story on
this tuesday afternoon this unfolded
just after midnight at a home on chicago
avenue off of industrial now this area
is referred to as naked city near the
strat that's where we find joe muller
live and joe the landlord didn't go
through the eviction process correct
christian that's right according to the
arrest report we received from metro
this all happened over late rent rent
that was not paid according to that
that's what the victims apparently in
the situation were missing their rent
and this is what happened two victims
were found shot outside of this home
here two women were found with gunshot
wounds and they both were deceased and
the third victim was transported to the
hospital now it was just after midnight
when shots were fired arnaldo lozano
sanchez does own the home and was also
living in it renting out half of it to
the victims a witness told police
several days ago sanchez became angry
about the occupants not paying rent and
told him he would handle this his own
way one of the other tenants who made it
out alive says sanchez was smiling and
laughing after pulling the trigger the
two women who died are identified in the
arrest report as dawn and paula the man
shot is a sephirano reyes he was shot
nine times i spoke to myron who lives
nearby he says he knows sanchez and is
surprised this happened
the guy was nice i you know i talked to
him i gave him cans you know all that he
came around my building all the time and
never would have thought he would do
something that
insane i feel bad for him because he
shouldn't have to resort to that but i
also feel bad for them because
this shouldn't have happened at all
according to the arrest report after the
shooting sanchez told neighbors nearby
to hold on to that firearm that was used
they told police where it was hidden in
a nearby bush sanchez now faces two
counts of open murder and one count of
attempted murder back out here live
serena reyes is in stable condition
tonight sanchez is set to be in court
tomorrow reporting live near saher in
las vegas boulevard joe mulvaney great
news now